[Musique]
ce soir on est au Café de l'homme ce
soir je vais rencontrer baptiste
Lecaplain
je voulais te présenter Baptiste je sais
pas si vous vous connaissez bien quoi
bonsoir mais toi ça te dérange pas de
faire des pubs non non c'est classe ça
peut être cool hein
qui est un jeune père de famille qui
vient s'accruster une soirée avec son
bébé sur son porte-bébé voilà truc que
je n'ai jamais fait non j'ai pas
un moment où tu l'as fait c'est une très
bonne idée là où tu vas faire dans ce
temps change pas ça
fait plus de 10 ans que je la connais
au-delà du fait que je suis un fan de la
première heure c'est devenu une amie et
on a eu l'occasion de travailler
ensemble elle avait toujours accepté
très gentiment de venir jouer avec moi
sur scène ou dans des vidéos que j'avais
pu faire et donc c'était logique que
j'accepte sa série
la fiction c'est l'argument songe le
cinéma c'est l'argument songe et moi je
suis un peu en conflit avec cette idée
tout le temps parce que il y a le
mensonge mais il y a aussi la vérité
excusez-moi
enchanté
vrais acteurs qui jouent leurs vrais
rôles à tourner dans les vrais lieux
donc je me suis arrangé avec ça c'est à
dire qu'il y a quand même il y a des
lieux qui sont mes vrais lieux par
exemple on a tourné dans mon vrai
appartement que j'avais à cette époque
là en 2017 c'est mon canapé que j'ai
fait venir de du Sud c'est mon canapé
c'est pas mon chien mais j'ai
essayé avec mon chien mais en tout cas
c'est le neveu de mon chien vous rendez
compte elle est folle très malade ah
ouais j'ai très très mal au ventre il
faut absolument que je mange du poulet
pour soigner mais c'est ça ouais on a
tourné avec ma vraie femme de ménage
Lucie qui s'appelle vraiment Lucie c'est
elle c'est son prénom on n'a pas changé
[Musique]
[Rires]
de mon chien mon appartement mes meubles
ma femme de ménage mon progrès mes
fringues
pareil je vous laisse sur mes fringues
mon jean mes chaussures mon sac à main
elle est débile elle se met des bateaux
dans les roues oui je parle de moi la
troisième personne comme Alain Delon
voilà donc c'est un peu difficile de
prendre de la distance avec le réalisme
lorsque vous tournez votre personnage
quand même c'est peut-être des choses
sur lesquelles je vais changer s'il y a
une saison 2
[Musique]
nous on va descendre la joie
et en fait après il y a un plan sur le
regarder
c'est la première fois que je travaille
avec Florence que je la rencontrais
d'ailleurs tu vois avec ce projet j'ai
le sentiment qu'elle a un imaginaire qui
est nourrit de beaucoup de femmes de
fantaisie sa fantaisie c'est fantasme et
elle ose les mettre en scène elle ose
rêver voilà
la scène de Sex and the City la version
américaine elle était dur à faire parce
qu'on n'est pas américaine bah on n'est
pas
et toutes les autres mais c'était hyper
amusant c'est notre investissement qui
est amusant toujours pour un comédien
c'est toujours le rêve d'enfiler une
perruque quoi qu'il arrive et fais-toi
la version américaine elle ne servait
qu'à mettre en relief la version
française qui suit juste après petite
commande
je voulais montrer c'est le glamour
versus là franchement
ce que j'essaie de montrer c'est juste
que quel que soit la volonté qu'on y
mette nous les français on arrivera
jamais à faire une série américaine
[Musique]
non on arrivera jamais mais c'est pas
grave on fait autre chose il faut
inventer autre chose
alors alors quoi
c'est joli non
ouais c'est joli mais c'est jeune ça
pourrait être ton fils
en ce qui concerne les situations et les
anecdotes il y en a qui sont totalement
fictives mais qui sont nés dans la
réalité et que j'ai finalement abouti en
fiction alors vous avez craqué
[Musique]
mais je suis pas allé jusqu'à ce point
la fiction permet d'imaginer ce qu'on
aurait pu être la relation si j'avais de
l'audace aussi la vie m'avait donné un
coup de pouce ou si la vie m'avait joué
un tour joyeux anniversaire
dans la réalisation c'est toujours dit
comédie en premier la comédie en premier
la comédie en premier donc là on reste
sur Baptiste j'essaie de bien parler de
la comédie et de l'action
la lumière elle est pas ce qu'elle est
parce que parce qu'on est plus drôle
dans cette prise là bah on va prendre
cette prise là donc c'est dur hein c'est
dur de c'est dur de privilégier la
comédie en fait
alors on essaie de allez regardons la
déplacer elle est moins dans le monde
elle est jolie elle est moins collée
j'ai une idée
[Musique]
faire les compétences qui m'ont entouré
c'est surtout ça c'est que moi j'ai pas
la compétence de fabriquer des belles
images est-ce que tu peux
alors
c'est ça qui est magique dans la série
le cinéma c'est que Dieu merci c'est un
travail collégial
alors on est aujourd'hui au Lido de
Paris pour tourner ce qu'est la
cérémonie des Globes de Cristal 2018 qui
est une fausse cérémonie mais qui est
très proche de la vraie
m'expliquer là Florence porte la même
robe que Audrey Lamy là c'est la cata
moi je suis ravie de cette situation ça
me chante Audrey
c'est une super partenaire et puis il y
a les toujours preneuse de plein d'idées
mais elle m'a écrit une super partition
merci de nous avoir fait tant rire
pendant toutes ces nombreuses années
[Rires]
elle est vivante elle est pas morte
Foresti il y aura des rires des aploses
tu vois
c'est cool parce qu'on sentait que on
était dans le même rythme quoi et puis
on a envie de déconner surtout on avait
envie de s'amuser de partir du moment où
on s'amuse pour de la comédie et ben ça
sent je pense
ce que je vais pas la tenir je vais
monter de profil ce qui est plus
ridicule entre eux
la comédie elle n'est souvent d'une
humiliation en fait dès que tu te sens
un peu humilié par ce monde ou rabaisser
c'est drôle donc on s'est plutôt
concentré là-dessus présente chanson
esti humoriste 45 ans dont 20 sous
antidépresseurs
dans la vie pour tout le monde je veux
dire qui que tu sois donc il suffit
juste de pas oublier ces moments-là de
vie ou tu as été bien ridicule
aujourd'hui donc avec Florence on a pris
notre premier cours de yoga on est en
tout début de course c'est-à-dire
réchauffements chacun ses choses
[Musique]
moi mon ambition c'est toujours d'être
plus proche de la réalité que ce soit
dans mes spectacles ou dans ce projet là
ça c'est pas mal la souffrance là
Florence largeur des hanches
Florence largeur du bassin
[Musique]
voilà
la honte ok en fait la misère du
quotidien elle est suffisamment drôle en
tout cas dans mon univers il y a
d'autres formes d'humour mais dans le
mien il y a pas besoin d'étirer grand
chose quoi la vie quotidienne est
suffisamment déplorable ou misérable
pour que ça se transforme très vite en
fourrure pas de précipitation
ça va tu t'es pas fait mal non tu vas à
la pharmacie que tu te retrouves avec à
te faire choper en flag par le beau
gosse du quartier avec un paquet de
couches pour l'incontinence ça c'est
encore mieux ce modèle pull-up c'est
intégré directement dans la culotte je
vois ouais ouais ça a l'air super mais
c'est pas pour moi donc on va rester
avec ça la célébrité aussi est parfois
te met dans des situations qui sont
grotes tu sais qui j'ai dans mon air
France forest
il y a des choses très drôles à jouer
puisque dans la rue Florence est souvent
arrêté non elle lui ressemble mais c'est
pas elle mauvaise foi de temps en temps
les choses naturelles donc si on pouvait
c'est que c'est de faire en sorte que la
caméra ça soit aussi drôle que quand tu
l'as vécu en fait c'est plutôt ça
excusez-moi madame fumer à l'intérieur
Catherine Deneuve qui fume la balle oui
je trouve que la fiction est toujours
moins drôle que la vraie vie c'est pour
ça que c'est très exigeant la comédie et
que c'est toujours très dur de de
retourner à la vérité de la situation et
puis la célébrité je veux dire c'est pas
tout le temps rose quoi la situation est
toujours plus drôle que ce que essaiera
de faire donc on est toujours à ça de
la vérité ça doit être fou d'avoir du
succès comme ça de l'argent de l'humour
et puis alors la célébrité c'est dingue
dingue oui enfin bon c'est pas non plus
l'essentiel de la vie bah nous on ce qui
compte c'est d'avoir la santé je pense
[Musique]